[Music]
hey folks welcome to Gamespot Studios
I'm your host Chris Waters is also your
host sea mcginness and it's time for
some civilization beyond Earth uh we're
going to be live streaming it taking a
look at two different cves uh the first
is Sha's robot Empire and then the next
will be my uh Alien hugging peaceful
Kingdom of happiness and joy that
correct So when you say robot Empire
obviously you refer I me cold heartless
uh demon robot Empire let use the
official terminology which is supremacy
that's the pathway that I've chosen
Supremacy is all about um transcending
the Mortal shackles of the organic being
in order to become a better faster
stronger robotic humanoid so it's about
embracing things like cybernetic
upgrades nanotechnology that kind of
like moral quandry of what makes a man a
man uh I'm basically creating like just
an entire civilization full of Adam
Jensen's um oh and as you can see I have
chosen the Brasilia faction sure so does
that uh the faction decisions like
basically folks as you can see we're in
turn uh like 192 right now so we're
pretty well into the mid game uh sort of
we'll reference stuff that we just we
sort of worked out in the early
parts of the game the early exploratory
turns and stuff and one of the things
you do is you Cho you make you have to
make a couple choices when you land on
the new planet and one is which
Corporation or which faction you're
going to be uh and they each have little
bonuses there's no like faction specific
units in this traditional Civ
civilization way that stuff is more uh
dependent on your Affinity uh Affinity
is just a quick briefer for you guys
know like you see Sean's mousing over it
in the top left there three affinities
Supremacy Harmony and Purity Supremacy
is the one Sean just talked about
Harmony is the one we'll see later in
which you kind which I chose which is
like you want to you know learn from the
alien life and uh sort of meld with them
and become a whole new species and then
uh Purity is the
like to hell with future robots to hell
with these freaky
aliens Earth was we did it right the
first time so we're going to make this
planet into Earth yeah you're you're
basically just you're terraforming the
whole place you're clear cutting
everything you're saying goodbye to the
aliens and uh it's you're basically
wiping out like all these foreign
species yeah and like you can see there
forests can we zoom in on the terrain a
little bit like these are forests uh and
they function you know they'll they'll
give you a production they'll give you a
food uh but these are like weird alien
ferns or like dangle trees I don't know
how would you describe those I think you
hit the nail on the head with dangle
trees tangle trees yeah see when you're
colonizing a new world it's really
important to uh you knowe and get
started make up names yeah so where
what's what are you doing right now
what's your Civ status so this press
build that we have uh it's got a 250
turn maximum and right now I'm at about
turn
190 um I actually played all the way to
completion I'm just kind of going back
and loading up a previous save file so
this was the point where um I had four
cities built up I had you got nice
little nice little coverage here yeah I
had a pretty good size Empire going and
I man managed to build up a lot of
trading relationships so I've got a
pretty good energy intake energy is
basically like it's it's the currency of
the game almost yeah um you need to
maintain energy into in order to like
maintain a strong a strong Army um
because you know units take energy yeah
certainly there's the maintenance costs
the the cost of buildings uh and then
you know you can use energy to buy units
uh as well um yeah so I I kind of
realized Iz that I wasn't going to get
to the victory state within the next 60
turns the supremacy Victory State just
to brief you guys is really cool uh you
basically build what's called an
emancipation gate and that is a gate
it's a real good euphemism you build
this gate you contact Earth and you tell
them hey guys we're coming back and
we're going to take your asses over
we're going to make listen all you
fleshy meatbag humans like we're super
men now don't you want to be like that
sorry that's not a rhetorical that's a
rhetorical question you're going to be
like that yeah uh so that yeah and the
the victory states are an interesting
thing to sort of talk about because
they're handled a little bit differently
uh in beyond Earth so uh Sean you're
going to you're going to be moving your
units in here uh but so the Victory
State like for example the Emancipation
gate you not not only you have to
research technology to you know unlock
it but you also have to build a unit or
build a structure on a tile next to one
of your cities called The Emancipation
gate it's a physical thing that exists
on one of the hex's outside of your
cities which makes it vulnerable to
anybody who thinks that your ideas for
the future are totally effed uh but then
once you've built that you actually have
to build a bunch of military units and
send them to that portal and send them
off to Earth so you actually have to
produce that Army and like the combat
strength of the units you send through
fills up a meter and once you hit this
the certain bar boom you did it um
that's Supremacy we can talk a little
bit
more about the the harmony uh
situation uh later when we take a look
at mine um so yeah let's so these just
look like some foot soldiers and are
they basically at this point I mean
these are Marines these are the kind of
upgraded version of the initial foot
soldiers that you get at the beginning
of the game uh I just began production
on the cinder troops okay which I'll um
I'll show you it's this is a look at the
tech web and you start in the middle and
you sort of go out you have to research
stuff like like pioneering in the center
is you have to research that to build a
colonist planetary survey you can
research that to Embark units but that
happens like really quickly so
exploration actually happens at a much
faster pace and is a little bit more
important because you can instead of
just like clearing Barbarian encampments
and getting gold the aliens are tougher
but you also the rewards are better in
terms of resources in terms of uh items
that you can recover yeah uh so since
Robotics are pretty important to the
supremacy pathway actually pretty
critical to the supremacy pathway uh I
unlocked the robotics uh element of the
tech web and um within that section you
unlock tactical robotics which grants
you the cinder troop I think that's how
you pronounce it cndr yeah totally um
and this is a unit that is unique to the
supremacy uh pathway it's a limited but
reliable robotic drone Soldier simple
Hardy defensive melee unit so you know
it's not like it's not a nuke it's not
going to win you the game instantly but
what I like about them is that they can
take a lot of damage and they have high
range um which makes them much more
useful when you say high what do you
mean high range I mean they can move
like so their movement speed is with the
Marines here it's well you only have one
left because Mar Marine has you moved it
one yeah right but the cinder Cinder can
move a little bit farther at a time cool
I'm not sure what the the the actual
number is we'll find out I'm going to go
ahead and just but you saw that it's
that unit required a level four in
Supremacy and so that's you throughout
through different actions you take in
different stuff you research in the game
you will level up your Affinity levels
and it's tracked in the top left wait
top left corner yeah of the screen uh
and you don't have to choose one you can
spread things around a little bit but uh
you know unless I think unless you
choose to like knock out a few Supremacy
techs you're probably not going to by
turn 200 be deploying unique Supremacy
units into battle Yeah if you sort of
spread it around a little bit then again
who knows what the other benef the other
benefits of taking other Tech paths will
be that's the kind of thing that is
really tough to sort of gauge in a
preview kind of situation or even after
just one game uh you know what kind of
flexibility you have within the
different affinities if you know because
there's obvious benefits to sort of
mainlining one and getting the uh
benefits of leveling up your Affinity
because they are Myriad like not only
does it allow special units uh like the
cinder it also will allow you to upgrade
your existing units and so that's kind
of the way that uh Civ beyond Earth
handles the like Spearman to pikemen to
musketmen like that you like instead of
researching the TCH for a new unit uh
you start with Gunners and those are
your soldiers with guns and then you get
a few uh levels in your affinity and you
can upgrade your unit so now all your
Gunners are gone they're replaced by
Marines and so they uh upgrade a little
bit more they gain bonuses to their
stats and they you have a chance to
choose a specific kind of unit upgrade
no I don't think it doesn't go Gunners
to Marines oh what oh sorry Gunners are
those the ranged ones yeah Gunners start
as they start as Gunners it might just
be soldiers or something I don't know um
so yeah cuz you have two different cuz
there you have the Marines and then in
front of them is that a a gunner yeah so
these are the gun so basically I think I
kind of trailed off earlier but I
realized that I wasn't going to get to
my Supremacy Victory uh so I decided hey
the Pan Asian Cooperative is down here
I'm just going to take them out cuz I
want to accomplish something before I
hit that 250 turn uh cap on this build
so I fig figured these guys made the
critical error of being the closest
faction to me so I'm going to take what
a bad bad mistake that b bad mistake so
when I was playing it I actually managed
to take them out pretty uh pretty easily
yeah but we're going to try it again um
so my Gunner Gunners have taken a little
bit of damage from a previous uh scuffle
so I'm going to have them fortify right
here just outside of that GRE you see
that green Cloud stuff that's the my
Asma of course
uh that's this unique thing to to Civ
beyond Earth that it exists on tiles it
damages your units maybe five or 10 HP
per turn that they are that they end
their turn on it but if you go the
harmony Affinity you
can like upgrade your units to heal from
my Asma uh which is great and then you
can this I haven't I didn't actually
affect this scenario but like you could
put a satellite into orbit pump down my
Asma onto your opponent's territory and
then just roll in so can you imagine
like all of a sudden like this faction
declares war on you those alien lovers
from up the way and all of a sudden the
skies are just like like this poison fog
comes down over your city and then they
like March over the hills with their
alien buddies we'll see the alien
buddies later yeah we'll see them um so
right now I'm trying to build up a few
more Gunners before I start taking out
this city because in traditional
civilization style you do need ranged
attacks to Siege a city cuz otherwise
you're just going to get clobbered yeah
you want to bring your full your full
might uh look poly Australia guy sure
hutama sure sure let's be friends you're
not anywhere really near me you are
irrelevant to me I'm going to Plate you
for the time being have you wait so with
my armor um which is kind of my
exploration vehicle unit yeah those
they're like the they upgrade from
combat Rovers they're they're fast yeah
they're fast um you know pretty pretty
decent strength um basically I'm just
Scouting Around Here because uh down in
this area uh is a pretty pretty happen
in Alien Hotpot so I want to make sure
that like uh a Siege worm doesn't show
up out of nowhere and just demolish my
troops when I'm trying to take out n
ntin over here oh The Siege worm is so
nasty so there's two units uh as part of
the aliens that are like boss aliens and
one of them is a Siege worm which is
kind of like the Dune Dune worm from
oracus and then uh the other is the
Kraken which is basically like this
floating Mountain tentacle Beast uh and
they have a lot of hit points and a
Siege worm can totally like take out a
city it one shots pretty much any unit
at certainly at this point in the game
yeah um but yeah you don't you don't
want to mess around with those The Siege
worm is the single biggest threat you
face within the first 10 to 20 turns of
the game because I had one of those guys
show up pretty much immediately oh
really oh yeah and it was bad um see
they didn't come and bother me
immediately I mean I had other alien
problems but uh I
built cuz I said I ended up settling
like real close to a nest that I didn't
have the force to clear but I was like I
need to claim this territory uh so alien
nests will pop up they're just like
Barbarian encampments but the alien
forces are much more diverse and deadly
than barbarians really ever were in Civ
uh so you kind of end up coexisting with
them a little bit more so I and I ended
up making these um like this ultrasonic
fence which you can see in the menu
there Sean hasn't built here you didn't
need to but it keeps aliens two hexes
away from your city which if you're just
building up a city can be pretty helpful
especially if it's an alien country so
I'm going to give you guys a little look
at the unit options that we have here
these are you know pretty much the
standard early game ones the colonists
are what allow you to venture off and
found a new city uh workers obviously
very critical trade vessels that kind of
stuff is pretty standard Civ stuff well
the trade stuff is different we'll talk
about that in a little bit cuz it's a
pretty interesting system um but yeah in
terms of basic units and stuff MH but
one of some of the more interesting
things are like this miasmic Repulsor
which is this kind of satellite that you
send up into the sky and it gradually
over a period of 10 turns starts to
dissipate the miasma clouds which for me
if I'm doing the supremacy route is
pretty critical because having those
things in my backyard is going to limit
the the opportunities I have to work the
terrain yeah and especially if you look
around the city that you're sieging now
there is a bunch of myma and I have to
be really careful of course wonders are
back Master Control Master Control all
worker units receive plus one movement
provides a free network in the city in
which is built um and this like if I
don't want to build any one thing
obviously I can just commit to getting
bonus resources yeah um but because I am
gearing up for battle I am going to
build I think another Gunner cinders
Cinder come on man we only need to see
those robot dudes I've got uh I've got
if you have a bunch going then maybe you
want the maybe you want your uh ranged
guys well I've got a couple Gunners I
should have three Gunners oh and here
are some Cinders I'll give you a little
look see it what these dudes are likeing
excellent wow those are what have I done
what have I done here all right so I
need to choose something in Dorado I'm
going to build there's also there's some
so the TAC jet is also there it's
actually a it's a jet it's a PL but it
doesn't
uh it can't leave a city like it needs
to it can't like go out on and fly on a
mission and then return to a city like
three turns later it's only based out of
a city or out of a carrier out of a
carrier yeah and I don't have the option
to build carriers yet so if I built one
of those it would pretty much be
defending this home city which within my
250 turns none of my cities were
attacked by other factions yeah me
neither um a unit needs you know what
Marine you just you're going to hold
tight just cool it buddy the Marines um
the tactic that I used when I was
sieging this city Marines were basically
Cannon fder like I had my Ranger set up
out here and I was attacking the city
and then I would bring the Marines in to
attack melee Style just to draw the
aggro from the defensive uh attack in
the city so they'd go in attack the city
would attack back and then I would get
them the hell out so they could fortify
to heal that way they were too
distracted to go after the uh the
Gunners the Gunners it it end up working
pretty well do you think we're going to
see it happen uh if if I move faster I
feel like I'm going a little slowly well
this has been an introductory second
let's kick it into gear and crank
through some turns uh you guys will see
some stuff in motion also a reminder
that we are taking uh questions and
stuff if you want to ask about this uh
in the Gamespot chat as well as on
twitch.tv/ Gamespot so go ahead and
chime in there if you guys want to know
anything uh we will do our best to
answer uh and yeah so I'm just going to
try to crank through these turns as
quickly as I can just so that we can get
into a battle Yeah scenario so while
we're doing that uh one thing you you
are going to see move uh once Sean or
you maybe saw a move there you saw some
other all right so here's actually there
a quests uh it just basically you built
an observatory so now it's asking you
should you direct your gaze towards the
heavens or uh should you look into uh
micro scale stuff and neutrinos and
waves and it's going to give you two
different benefits plus to Naval
movement from observatories or the other
one got to move quick we got to see some
action here but so quests happen uh all
throughout the beyond Earth experience
like when you come upon new landmarks in
the environment when you're exploring
when you uh research new technologies
when you build new buildings in your
cities these are the cinder troops by
the way little little robot sylon guys
oh yeah got a little like triangle heads
let's see them let's see them run come
on well they will run as soon as I
trigger the next turn all right maybe we
yeah no no you have to you just have to
move your your gunboat so this gunboat I
it would benefit me more if it was over
here but that's going to take about 19
turns so I'm just going to put it here
in case this guy sends out any melee
units um he's just outside a range of
the gun booat so I'm basically he's just
an insurance measure just going to hang
out there yeah all right so you chill um
this is my Gunner traversing by C so the
Gunner is going to you head over this
way once I have I'll feel comfortable
once I have three Gunners placed outside
the city walls uh and then I'll start
attacking all right zoom in before you
do the next turn so we can watch some
units move uh go up to your Cinder yeah
right there is fine that should be good
those guys will maybe move um thing is
the camera Auto redirects to to happen
in HS happening
let's so the quest system is kind
of uh
this tool that
lets it's meant to like sort of
cultivate your own myth like to sort of
tell help you tell your story about like
the decisions you would have to make if
you were that's an are the the cavian
prot these These are so these soldiers
here are not who you're trying to fight
right um these cavian protector fools
well this is this is just the trade
route guys so I no those are combat
Rovers I think these yeah look go the
little hex the the purple uh and blue
hex above them their little unit
indicator oh that is a combat yeah so
those are from the KP uh they're maybe
just exploring I don't know I think
they're probably just exploring actually
this is an interesting view real quick
let's just take cuz like you see all
right here's a farm that pretty
recognizably a farm this is like some
kind of oh I can't my arm disappeared
but then there's like uh there's this
float Stone you've got you've got a
plantation for tubers and for mushrooms
so you like basically are growing those
uh you've got a petroleum field and
you've got a paddock where you have
these like little bugs that you're
keeping to harvest their resources uh
but float stone is one of these so
there's like a couple different tiers of
resources like strategic resources and
then I don't know just like bonus ones
I'm not sure what the exact terminology
is but you know what I'm saying like
yeah the ones that like boost food
production or production on a specific
hex or the ones that become uh usable to
create units so that's forite xenomas
float Stone titanium geothermal
petroleum uh I think are the six um
let's see oh these guys are these guys
are blocking me sorry that's not a
phrase I should use on the stream but
they're uh yeah jamming up they're
jamming up your your troop movements
they are clear out dudes uh we got a
quick request from kichi in the twitch
chat to click on the mini map the little
eyeball oh this
yeah she wants that this user wanted to
see the Strategic uh view but this is
really just uh I'm not sure exactly
which one of those so yeah you've got
like different resource icons yield
icons you can bring up The Hex grid and
you can show trade routes uh so talk
about trade routes in a minute but uh
yeah I guess the Strategic view you were
thinking was not uh is maybe different
here all all right we have a bunch of
questions I'll try to take a look at
some of these folks are curious about
how it runs performance wise um so we
are running on an
Alienware X what are those called X 51s
xlb 900 XP G yeah U and we have it every
setting is cranked up um and it's
running flawlessly so it's um no I don't
think you need a super powerful rig to
to run this nice
uh Aries 42 in the games spot chat
curious what the little plus sign left
of the icons on the bottom right is uh
so in the bottom right you've got your
your over over on the other side of Sean
you've got the big circle which is sort
of a unit needs orders I really wish
these guys were not standing here
completely just freaking get out of the
way then you've got uh the globe which
is diplomacy you've got the book which
is virtues uh which we can take a brief
look at uh the eyeball and the the
magnifying glasses covert operations the
triangle
is unit upgrades maybe not
sure the compass is I think
quests and the satellite it shows you
the orbital layer uh and then the plus
gives you a couple other options it'll
show you basically the breakdowns of
like economic overview trade overview
military overview just those lists that
sort of uh you know allow you to get
information about your C gives different
aspects so trade let's I'm going to talk
about trade for a sec because trade you
can
uh like I think you can set up trade
agreements with
people sounds about right uh to like
give them you know give them resources
but to give them the special resources
the ones we talked about before that are
actually represented like straight up at
the top of the the screen there's six
little resource things in a row Shawn
only has four of them so far uh I think
you can trade those through diplomacy
but in terms of like there's this sort
of daily trade system and that's you
build a trade Depot in your city you
build a trade vessel uh or a trade
Convoy to go over land or sea and then
you just ch once it's built you choose
another city to send it to it can be
your own City it can be uh a city from
another faction or it can be uh one of
these Standalone stations which you can
actually see if Sean Scrolls down a
little bit uh the Church of Dawn's light
that's a standalone station it's never
going to expand it's only there to be
traded with uh or eliminated if you want
to settle there um but these trade
routes give you re like you give
resources to the people you're trading
with you get from the people you're
trading with and they just automatically
go for 20 turn and every turn you get
that benefit regardless I think
regardless of how long how far away they
are so you can trade with someone whose
civilization is all the way around the
other side of the continent your boat
will just go back and forth It's
vulnerable to attacks or you know if you
send it through alien country uh though
there are perks that allow you to uh
make your trade vessels not attacked by
aliens uh but it's it ended up being
pretty essential for me and my economy
cuz my energy situation got real bad
yeah mine is actually I have so many
troops now that my energy situation I'm
only at plus one whereas previously I
was at what like plus 18 so I might
switch production on one of these cities
to focus
on energy development there we go so now
I'm back up to plus n you know then
again like of course energy has its its
benefits you know definitely buying uh
you know buying units buying buildings
can help accelerate your sort of
production but I also found that like I
you know I was losing a lot of energy
per turn and it was it was okay like I I
handled it I handled it by stealing from
my factions actually I just realized I
was making kind of a boner move there I
was i' I've been building a bunch of
Gunners out of force of habit when I
probably should have been building
artillery cuz they're a little bit more
focused on taking out cities but I don't
know I like the kind of Versatility of
the uh of the Gunner so screw it rolling
in rolling the dice on the pan Asian
Cooperative cool there you guys are
chilling my Cinder so I feel like I've
got my three
Gunners about to be in place I've got
some Cinders two Cinders I got some
armor to kind of go in attack just draw
aggro a little bit and my my Marines
which are just cannon fodder so I feel
like we'll probably declare war within
the next two or three turns and you guys
can see a little bit of combat turn
based
combat
all right uh well aanat is curious about
a city state versus a station so a city
state you know from Civ five those
things could grow territory they could
produce units they could improve their
areas you would have relationships with
them where you have sort of status uh a
station has none of that the only thing
that like they don't grow they don't
produce units they don't have the only
thing they have is like you trade with
them so if you set you set up a trade
route to them then you can like level
them up they'll do like tier two tier
three uh and give you a little bit more
and I think there's some sort of
competition element where like if your
opponents want to trade with them as
well I'm not sure if it's first one
there gets it or you know or exactly how
that pans out but they are so far the
only role they've had for me are trading
with the station
uh what's the second thing oh some
sometimes they'll be in quests they'll
be involved in quests and so actually uh
maybe some refugees from Sha's old sha
civilization landed on my planet and I
was going for the harmony situation and
I was like listen we want to respect
these aliens we want to get in line with
their biology and this station came in
and they were all they were basically
cyborgs and they're like look we're
cyborgs we're going to do our thing here
yeah and I was like I don't think that's
cool guys and they're like well we're
just gonna we're gonna do it and then so
my quest became sort of make decisions
am I going to allow them to settle am I
going to trade with them and if not uh
if I want you know I finally it took it
led me to the point where we had such
ideological differences that my quest
was to destroy them uh which I didn't do
I actually ended up trading with them
and then destroying them later because I
wanted to settle where they were all
right I think we're just about ready to
declare war I just want to make sure
that my troops are positioned in an
optimal
fashion um let's see gunboat that
gunboat is not going to contribute
anything to this fight I can already
tell uh armor maybe you the Armor should
be on the other side of the Gunners like
what if it was across the top of your
Gunners because it can it could zoom in
and
hit I feel like well he can't really go
through these guys so I might have to
bring
them uh all right you're going to take a
little my Asma hit that's okay you're
not going to die where C at bro get
those get those Robo Robo jerks in there
bring the
syons Marines are just blocking the P so
this is tricky because a it's a narrow
little uh ismus and B there's some my
Asma so I kind of have a funnel of
movement to actually get around here but
just take the myma hit it's all right
I'm going to do a I'm going to save the
game real quick in case something goes
horribly around
PC crashes or something and I
believe I'm going to do a quest decision
free maintenance for networks Quest
decision so this so they give you a
little paragraph to read about sort of
you know you've got Network links so it
gives you a chance to disseminate
knowledge digitally uh be it
technological or cultural so you can
choose it you know technological free
maintenance for networks which means
they won't buildings won't cost energy
or plus one culture and culture is what
gets you to unlock virtues it's kind of
analogous to the policy system from uh
Civ 5 but it's got some tweaks where uh
it doesn't it's not it's a little more
flexible than the policies it's not like
you choose this one you go down and
complete it and then you choose your
next which is kind of how I did policies
I don't know if you guys spread it
around more or not but this one it's
sort of a you know there are four
columns actually we just click on the
policy thing real quick so I don't have
to make it do it with my the uh down
below under unit needs orders I think
it's the book yeah virtues sorry so
you've got might Prosperity knowledge
industry and of course you're going to
get bonuses if you go down the line and
get a certain amount uh like sea already
has no across the top actually by the
fist sea already has Synergy bonus on
might so he get plus five strength and
range strength for all his units but if
you go across like the Roman numeral one
Roman numeral 2 area so if you Mouse
over the first uh you also have a
Synergy bonus across uh the top if you
click if you Mouse over just to the
right of the Roman
numeral on the left side yeah right
there so you was able to choose one free
virtue because he took five across the
first tier of Virtues uh and so working
your way down through that is it's
pretty neat there's some pretty powerful
stuff in there uh you know free units to
to bonuses to production to attributes
for your uh various units etc etc um so
that's virtues you get it by culture
there are not like a huge amount of
buildings that produce culture early on
and that's something that I don't know
if you you experienced this Sean
actually do you want
to are I want to ask you question if you
want to go if you want to kick in gear
going all right let's do it I'm going
into gear here let's fight Let's uh
let's see some are you close enough to
attack this oh you most certainly are
all right all right zoom in a little bit
let's see this in action they set up
their their tripod gun
you close enough oh good you are too oh
yeah and actually so this is this is
going well in a city that I took I think
I had moved my artillery in and I was
bombarding them but I moved one of my
artilleries into a forest and I don't
think you can fire out of a forest as
artillery I don't know I I didn't I was
within the amount right amount of hexes
but I wasn't sure exactly what I was
doing wrong um but we'll take a look at
my Civ situation in a little bit this
way
so I'm feeling pretty good this guy does
not have um any units in the area so I
can kind of bombard the
city Gunner's taking one on the chin and
that's so that was why you uh previously
when you took this city you likes to
have melee units in there yeah I might I
don't I made the mistake of not bringing
the melee units in quickly enough
so resarch artificial
intelligence whates that give you what
do you get all right so I get cell
cradle which is a thing specialist and
specialist slots are a are a real
important thing right from the beginning
uh surveillance web this has to do with
covert Ops which we can talk more about
when we check out my game because I did
that much more robustly than sea did and
the marov Eclipse which is just a cool
name for I'm not exactly sure
what military units gain experience 50%
and of course there are civilopedia
entries on all these things like to re
you know and with like backstory and
it's actually you know reading the the
civilopedia in previous cives is always
interesting but this is interesting in a
different way because it's basically the
guys at fraxis like making stuff up
drawing from sci-fi extrapolating from
current scientific Trends and
developments to sort of create these
texts and these things which one which
one do you think is going to give me the
most immediate return uh Tech wise yeah
well if you I at this point you know
would I would look for a Supremacy uh
yeah cuz I feel like once I get my
Affinity up that'll give me a nice
little yeah so like synthetic thought
down there that's 21 turns I guess yeah
I mean at this point we're not going to
see this Tech research so but you you
know you like looking at this sort of
tech web you have the the main teexs and
then the what do they call Leaf text
which are the sort of two attached to
the one main one the branch and leaf
system I think is what they call it yeah
yeah yeah and so you can see that you
know it shows
you the the Civ the Civ bonuses you get
the units you unlock the buildings you
unlock and the Affinity bonuses you get
uh so I definitely spent a lot of time
staring at that yes okay this is nice
this is something that I've always
enjoyed about uh the Tactical element of
Civ combat it's the trade-off here do I
improve their stats or do I go for the
really quick return and just recover 50
HP
um and that's obviously something that's
been in previous Civ games but you can
see how it's applied here I'm going to
recover HP because uh we're going to
jump over to Chris's save file in a
while and I just want to bombard the sh
you want sure that this thing gets
worked yeah I'm going to don't worry
about that CU there's so there now
there's a combat Rover right next to you
you should probably take these guys
probably is the only option although so
if I don't you can't attack the city
because they're adjacent to you maybe oh
yeah so it's really your only choice at
this point the so the problem I'm facing
now is that the city will recover health
with every turn so if I if I don't keep
wearing it down I'm basically just
taking damage to no to no gain so
obviously this is the more short-term
threat so I'm going to have to go after
them that does who doer in the twitch
chat thanks for that uh forests mess up
your range and movement in general uh
tip yeah that's sort of what I thought
about my artillery situation before uh
all right who's it going to be take out
that combat Rover yeah they would
probably cause some trouble for your
Gunners did you get the cinder up there
to take him out my Cinder so I'm
planning on using the cinder as like
once I get the city down to a certain
amount of health I'm going to go in I'm
going to bring those guys in there to
finish the job I want your robots to
attack those other
things you Gunners are you got you got
plenty of robots coming down the way I
want those robots see attack that combat
Rover okay we'll do it if it can oh you
did next turn cuz they're out of moves
no but the ones down there by the
city those ones oh
well oh taking some shots at your
Gunners fine going to come across the
river I might oh okay all right oh The
Rovers straight up they're like oh god
oh we got to get out of here guys uh
have your
Gunners oh what are those Marines doing
out there there uh these marines yeah I
forgot I have these guys on alert so I'm
going to bring them in uh just as cannon
fire just to try to draw the attention
mhm instead of them killing my
Gunners and I should probably bring
in these marines as well you you guys I
hope you like my asthma cuz you're about
to stand in listen man war is hell you
guys got to breathe a little alien
poison fog you're going to suck it up
and do
it suck it up and do it that's my uh
General strategy for civilization and
all video games really just suck it up
and do it um you can bombard with
another Gunner
right another Gunner yeah the one that
you healed before just uh oh I already
did that's yeah so I already bombarded
with these two those guys are just tie
they're real I've got the cers coming in
so okay here's a
question it's costly but not that costly
do it we're going to attack these guys
oh want to attack anyway so that's going
to wear them down so on the next turn I
should be able to reduce their health
completely um I feel pretty confident
that I'm going to take over this city
this is really not going to be a problem
they're hurting they're they are on the
ropes you you should use your armor to
just chase down those dudes over there
total dip oh really yeah I mean they're
evacuating like those Gunners are
piecing out yeah they have abandoned the
city the armies are fleeing the
citizenry is in disarray
oh my artillery is done so why don't you
guys just take your sweet time coming
down this way take your time missile
trucks the war is probably going to be
over by the time you get here don't
worry about it so I was telling you like
trade with stations will give you
resources there are also military
stations I was trading with one and
every time the trade route was completed
I got a new art I got a new missile
Rover which is the predecessor to
artillery so it's not just economic
benefit uh depending on which stations
you set up trades with
what do I want to build I'm going to
build I'm out of so the Cinders because
they're unique units they require
special resources in this case it's
farite a very cheeky named um is that
for forite is not a real thing right
they Nam that after themselves I want to
make sure it wasn't a real thing and the
studio was named after it and now it's
just full circle no it's uh they um I
hosted a panel with them at PX Prime and
they said they just had used it as a
placeholder name for most of development
and then yeah and then at some point
they're like all right no if we go
forward we are really calling this thing
forite and it's the stuff that you can
see uh right up there the yellow stuff
that looks like a blooming onion uh
that's forite going to go in here good
idea cross that river cross that River
okay so we're going to try to wear these
guys down and then finish the job with
either
either those Marines or this Cinder
who's not doing so
hot there's yeah those there's those
Marines too so you could let's bring I'm
going to use these as a little buffer to
protect my my gun you could just attack
the city with those Marines it looks
like you're Maring this might actually
do
it I mean you're going to take some
missiles to the face and here we go H
the Conquering Hero I'm going to Annex
the city
uh and as you can see it's mine however
there is a health penalty for a while
because these guys are not super happy
that they just got demolished and then
annexed I don't understand why yeah can
you they're part of the Great robot
Dominion now and uh yeah so health is
uh it's not it's a little bit analogous
to happiness uh it sort of is something
you need to maintain across your
civilization actually the more cities
you have the harder it is to maintain
that health so as you can see sea just
chose to build a clinic that's going to
help him with some science and some
health but if you Mouse over the health
you can see the penalty for having low
Health in the like negative 1 to
negative not 10 range isus 10 science in
cities minus 10 culture uh I think if
you get less healthy than food
production takes a hit you'll you'll
produce as much food as you need to
support your population but not extra so
you won't really grow yeah it health is
it's definitely a long-term concern um
for our purposes it's not really
something we have to worry about on a
live stream where we're playing on Old
save files sure and when we're playing a
preview build that only that is only
meant to go to like sort of the mid not
really late game yeah so um so yeah I
feel like we should probably jump over
to your save file now okay we've taken
over that City just to uh give you guys
a little look so my world is a bit
different than Chris's you'll notice
that when we pull open his safe file in
a minute minute I chose the um the kind
of continuous protean continent um where
the layout is basically you have one
giant Pia p is protan is the whatever
term they used in the selection but it's
it's essentially of like what the Yeah
floor and fawn is like but yeah it's
analogous to Pangia uh so basically it's
one big continuous continent um these
are some of the other factions around
here and then you'll find just tiny
little Island
when you go out exploring you'll also
find Krakens who are going to kill the
out of you like instantly you will
that's they're bad news so that's that's
my world but Chris's we can load that up
uh so sort
by let's see sort by name uh
coslov why don't we go to why don't you
take this I'll take we're going to do a
little little Trader rooo little swaper
RO with the uh control
situation I'm going to go ahead and load
General Vadim klov uh let's
do this war also War
imminent and we'll see how that goes I'm
G to move this table a little bit or no
scooch so yeah the affinities that so
Sean was in the supremacy Affinity so
now you're going to see the harmony
Affinity uh
which instead of sort of the first
the first Supremacy specific unit was
the cinder that sort of that robot
Soldier the first
um Harmony specific unit is these guys
the xenos Swarm which is basically a
pack of aliens and then some foot
soldiers with them they're just like
rolling together in a happy crew real
quick uh Aries 42 had an interface
question he was wondering what the
little plus icon is to the left of the
bottom right icon okay so this is trade
route overview I can see I've got trades
going from my Capital to other cities go
to benu to some minor Powers it shows
you like what how many turns in your
trade cycle and what you're getting out
of the trade and then you've also got
technology web the notification log
military overview which just shows me a
list of my all my units really so it's
not just my military units uh you know
my Cruisers my xenos swarms and stuff
it's also all my trade convoys it's my
workers it's my and even my orbital
units my solar collector uh
so I guess and I'm not sure what this
Supply is here right because base Supply
cities population this house this this
somehow adds up to the total like units
you can supply maybe without taking a
penalty uh to energy I'm exceeding it so
my Supply is negative 1 so maybe that's
why I'm losing 51 energy per turn uh
which is a lot so yeah I'm spending 140
on unit maintenance I don't have holy
you're atga 51 energy yeah I per
turn look I don't have wow I don't have
wow what did you do wrong I don't know I
don't have 140 units so obviously
there's some kind of multiplier involved
of the costs of units like a xenos swarm
I don't know how much they cost per turn
it doesn't really clarify that um but
you know that's that's my energy
situation it's bad so how am I managing
the energy situation you ask through
covert Ops so it's all just happens in
this menu and basically I've got agents
out I got I'm stealing I'm siphoning
energy from the uh African something
Guys these guys nice African Union ni
Chris from suitar Jamar uh I'm we're
we're friends we're trading but I am I
am siphoning energy from him I'm
stealing technology we're going to see
how all that works out next time
actually I have to choose so I can
choose an operation basically you can
assign a spy to a city every city has
Intrigue levels my city actually has one
Intrigue which is not cool with me um
but as the Intrigue level goes up it's
going to depend it's going to uh alter
what you can and cannot do so for
example when you first go to a city you
establish a network it gives you
information about the city so that you
can click on it and see stuff like what
they're researching what they're
producing what their health is like what
their yield is like etc etc uh and then
you can siphon energy which is steel
Energy Siphon science steel science
steel technology recruit defectors uh
which recruits a random military unit
that just placed near Capital hack
satellites that deorbit satellites
within five hexes of the city which can
be a good offensive maneuver or just
help like their economy a little
bit
Ceta uh which you just claim the control
of the city if it's successful dirty
bomb you detonate a nuclear device in
the city reducing the population by a
hat that is mean as hell and only Purity
notice that only a purity score of uh
Affinity of 11 can make that happen so
what's my equivalent call worm strike
which basically means I put one of those
Thumpers in the city and a Siege worm
comes to mess that place up uh the
supremacy version is sabotage which just
straight pillages all improvements
within three tiles of the city which
when you get your city's pretty big is
is pretty mean so so you can do some
pretty mean I'm going to recruit
defectors I haven't actually done that
we're not going to see that come come to
yield un it's funny like the covert Ops
thing is not something that I really
concern myself with because like I was
so gung-ho about just focusing on my
robotics upgrades and getting to that
Victory State that I was like a total
isolationist faction yeah up until the
point that I wasn't and started going
after the PAC muring people um so I
actually kept my spies at home just to
defend my cities um I didn't I never
actually sent them out on Covert Ops
missions so this is my area you can
start to see how I'm uh I look a little
mine look a little different they're
starting to get these buildings uh that
look a little bit green a little bit
more curved edges Sean's were a little
bit more sort of black monolithic with a
little orange flare that's how one of
the ways that civilizations take on a
different look depending on your
Affinity situation uh this is a wonder
that I built uh I think it's the let's
see let's go down my Capital City no go
to the city
please uh it's the
panopticon which gives me plus one
culture and all military units receive
plus one sight so this is what the city
screen looks like pretty familiar uh you
know it shows you what kind of energy
output you have where your citizens are
working uh you can see you know I've got
a lot of Specialists slots right away
not a a whole lot of people work in the
specialist game yet um but you can you
know use this to focus on culture or
production or food or energy or science
uh then of course you've got your
production thing here and you've got
your purchase uh list here I do have a
Tac jet in this city I or it's a needle
jet now yeah that's the next stage up
from the you guys can't actually see it
do anything
unfortunately uh actually I'm going to
rebase it so that it just so you can see
it quickly fly fly let's
see there go that was the needle jet uh
now I have a trade Convoy these things
their turns expire and so you know you
pick I don't have a lot of options here
so I'm just gonna go with usek it's my
boy usek usek uh quick oh gosh all right
yeah you're you go ahead to
kbl set those going apparently a lot of
my trade routes are up see and then like
this is not really an optimal trade it's
plus three and it's like helping helping
my internal development but I'd really
like to send it somewhere else but the
only other city on the continent is
ashraa which I am I have just declared
war on and I'm moving in on there's also
a happy coincidence that there are
aliens kind of messing with them at the
same time so uh it's going to it's going
to be a little tricky but let me just
zoom out and show you guys the world uh
for a sec it's doing that weird thing
where a little weird bug where this
there's some black on the tiles but I so
one of the perks I took when I first uh
landed was see to see all the edges of
continents so I could see that I was on
a continent this size I could see where
this this uh you know straight was I
could see this conon I could see these
tiny little islands like here there's
one there are some uh down over here and
so that really helped my exploring uh
game so I had a bunch of explorers out
this continent's almost entirely un
unsettled and I actually have an
Explorer going here to uh check out this
ancient
tomb um but exploring is a real real
good tactic to to undertake right from
the GetGo so I want to move some xenos
swarm guys in to enemy
territory uh these gunboats are just
basically there to be Canon fodder
because they go down in one shot from
the city so I'm not eager to move them
in uh but I they're not super sturdy I
do want have my xenos swarm move in I've
got I do have artillery I parked them
out in the on the sea so that I could
move here because I've like this was the
forest that I bombarded from earlier and
I couldn't bombard because the freaking
Forest uh so this again you know I'm a
slave to terrain but instead of my
asthma giving me problems it's uh this
narrow crack between these crazy Canyons
uh giving me just this little narrow way
to go up and mess with these guys um I
declared war okay so actually I declared
war and this person's cities there's one
on my continent and there's two over
here and I feel like I want to hedge my
bets when it comes to uh War like I
don't want to be the only enemy in the
game so we check out the diplomacy
situation and the thing to note here it
shows you you know the relative score uh
the who's beating me oh oh sweet I'm
declaring war on the person who's
beating me I didn't even know uh it
shows you the Affinity uh sort of
Alliance that other all the other civs
have gives you an update on what kind of
Wonders they have gives you up like
shows you tells you that like you have a
mutually beneficial trade route you have
no conflicting territorial claims they
believe you are a warmonger so it gives
you sort of a a clear kind of breakdown
of where your relationship is at but
with Dow Ming SOA
earlier uh we I gave her some titanium
in exchange for a favor so we're going
to call in that favor so that
you make an alliance with us and that
will make them uh actually do I even
need to spend in a favor do you want to
do you want to have an alliance H I
didn't even need to spend the favor why
not all right so now they're going to
declare war
on
kavor uh so they're declaring war on
them now and they're over here so
hopefully that will mess with them a
little bit and uh I'll get
to I can City bombard this worker I
would love for this worker to land so I
could steal them but I just send them to
the Briny beef
instead oh what my city bombardment game
is hella weak yeah that was that was
lame not great all right let's see let's
let's move these guys around around a
little bit who needs
orders okay so I've got this guy over
here actually I just made this Cruiser
because my other one got killed by a
freaking Kraken uh this is a kraken by
the way it's like a floating mountain
and I'm just you'll notice when it
attacks you it's got big tentacles and a
big old mouth I'm just going to mess
with this thing yeah go for it there's
no way that could possibly end poorly
I'm going to shoot
it and it's going to be like yeah
I'm unperturbed by that so we'll see
what happens next turn once the uh
Kraken gets
cranky a r I'm coming for
you so I wanted to make a move on this
city a because I had kind of reached the
point the same point Shawn did which was
like all right let's make something
happen here we're not playing the long
game uh but also all right I'm getting
bombarded my
artillery oh double artillery
bombardment
no still
alive still still alive uh oh the bugs
are going
away oh sweet so I didn't notice that
before but
apparently
uh it just gave me the message I
plundered 100 energy from a trade Convoy
so now I have well I have a lot more
energy for that reason but I also have
more energy because I siphoned 658
energy from uh the African Union and
they're none the wiser so if I'm losing
50 per turn and it takes 20 turns to uh
siphon energy I'm I don't know kind of
breaking even not quite in that case I
stole the technology mechatronics from
the Civ that you chose uh so now we're
going to go ahead
and I don't know steal another
technology and you siphon more energy
and you're recruiting defectors awesome
the powers of
Espionage so my culture is flourishing I
can now choose a new virtue since I'm at
War I might be tempted to go
with
uh military one but the only two I can
choose aren't really anti- City so I'm
going to look at my bonuses like I've
got a Synergy bonus waiting for me plus
10 production on energy and whatnot that
could be helpful and I've also got a
Bonus here plus 10% energy if I choose
one more so if I choose one from here
I'm going to get those bonuses uh 15%
prodction towards wonders five energy in
the capital capital sure let's see how
what this does to my drastic energy bad
situation now I'm only at - 28 instead
of50 you're still in a real sh energy I
moved the needle your energy situation
is a bag of
garbage it is pretty I don't I really am
startled to see you it went that poorly
I was startled too I don't know how to
manage my energy situation I feel like I
have way too many like I don't know uh
units or something or buildings anyways
I'm going to build a Zeno Nursery cuz I
got my xenom mass Improvement were you
so when you were um
um
uh building what are the little items
called like the farms and stuff like
improvements tile improvements when you
were doing tile improvements did you
build many generators you've got a few
uh I think that they have my I have my
workers automated and I don't have them
set to not change so they might be like
maybe your workers are the ones who
screwed you over cuz I did that all
manually and I made sure to Pepper in
plenty of generators maybe they are they
looks like they might be plowing under
these farms and making generators
because my situation is so dire uh I
have a quest decision that came up this
uh is the same Observatory one that sea
had so plus two City strength or plus
two Naval unit we'll go for Naval
movement uh we already handled the tech
stealing although mechatronics what is
mechatronics so first person
mechatronics what did I just steal
mechatronics is the name of my upcoming
rap album mechatronics yeah I I'm
intrigued yeah so it allows me to build
something that I can't because it's a
purity thing uh H this Optical surgery
gives me some health nope that's a
silica that's a Supremacy thing and plus
25% production for wonders if I build a
crawler what the hell is a crawler so
then you of course you can read all this
stuff uh and so of course they have the
history of all this stuff uh what a
crawler is but then also they make up
quotes which are kind of fun like this
is John Henry smiled at the crawler and
he said sure you can move a lot of dirt
let's see who gets to the
movich discontinuity first and he picked
up his shovel and waited for the
starting gun so that's like imagine that
you know the the cultural myths John
Henry is an American uh sort of folk
hero uh who famously uh fought against a
steam drill or something and to see who
was faster man or machine and he won but
he died yep uh so here here's my here's
my Kraken friend who I'm let him uh let
him kill you I I mean he's going to kill
me exercise I'm going to range attack
him I'm not going to get killed or I'm
not going to kill it so you're really
taking advantage of the range on that
gunboat by putting yourself in the tile
immediately next to him look man this is
this is live stream strategy level right
right now oh worker are you going to
land so I can steal you I'm just going
to let that worker land so I can steal
it all right uh artillery has to set up
for ranged attack that takes one of its
movement points and then uh we're going
to go ahead and missile bombard these
guys eat it and then the xenos Swarm is
going to go to work don't remind me
again okay they died a lot
but they did 21 damage so it's it's
happening oh we got another xenos swarm
here where are you going
um here
a unit needs orders Cruiser you could I
think the cruiser can range to attack
the
city so why not little offshore
bombardment hey eat it and you're just
going to chill and we're going to go to
the next turn see what asria has in
store for
us
it's thirsty work getting blown up in
the oil fields of War so at first I was
like holy look at all these oh damn
look the aliens just moved in they are
getting cheeky as hell so you can tell
the alien sorry you can what happened
here I think maybe you got killed by the
Kraken why is
my where is this Cruiser from no this is
my cruiser oh it's just the oh the
Kraken is just moving on my city oh
great great hey uh no come come back
back over here I think this is this is
my trade vessel so my trade vessel is
can be can get kened come back over here
you jerk actually I might just try to
kill this Kraken go for it all right uh
now my Explorer is over here going to
build an action going to construct an
expedition on this ancient tomb and
replace the ancient tomb
resource
uh sorry what were you saying Sean oh I
was just saying it was interesting
because I looked at your troops and I
was like oh when are these aliens
show up and then I realize that those
are your those are my dudes those are
your dudes cuz in between those aliens
are yeah you there's a soldier here uh
and but yeah the wolf beetles are
totally the alien faction these mantor
these scorpions are aliens that you can
encounter they are hostile uh I don't
think I can build alien drones I'm going
to that's neat because I for me like the
aliens were just a means to an end like
they were an infestation that I had to
clear out I mean I didn't have to clear
them out because I wasn't doing like the
full Purity thing where I'm just like
just demolishing everything like for me
the aliens were just more of a
nuisance but obviously for you they are
a nuisance though like they are like a
pretty substantial uh problem these guys
might die oh no but I've got veterany so
we're going to recover some H there you
go heal up and uh throw yourselves upon
this city it will be
ours
all right Cruiser do you want
to because I don't think I I think I can
only ranged attack these workers I can't
capture them with the cruiser uh which
is kind of a bummer because I I like to
capture workers yep my artillery was
killed I get it you're going to also
bombard the city hey why
not this city is boned they're pretty
boned yeah uh oh wow the they're kind of
burned and on mildly charred um yeah so
next
turn next turn you will be mine let's
see what this Kraken does actually so
you can see that the this logo is
normally green but it gets yellower and
then red depending on the aliens General
aggression level so that's why these
aliens are so aggressive and coming up
on this city and causing them problems
uh see now they've got their ranged
bacor coming in um the aliens are pissed
and I'm not exactly sure why oh we're
gonna try to maybe because maybe because
I've been shooting the Kraken probably
because you've been shooting the Kraken
it's probably because of the Kraken
shooting I've been doing trying trying
to chase it away from my shipping lanes
SL kill it do you think I really you
kill this Kraken with that gunboat I'm
going to be really impressed thank you I
don't think you're going to do it
because eventually that Kraken is going
to be like this is some yeah
and he's just going to stroll over and
kill you so you can see this trade route
is a little bit lucrative in a different
way when you do it to a station um it's
only food in production that I'm trading
among my own Empire but it's I'm also Al
getting energy and culture from Trading
with this station so definitely if there
are stations nearby you can trade with
keeping those trades up uh can be very
beneficial
although H you might also just be really
losing a lot of money like me oh God die
from
Aliens oh xenos swarm you didn't get you
didn't do it all right you're going to
you're going to finish them up mop them
up boys and beasts
yeah all right so annexing Sean just
went ahead and did that right away it I
mean it makes it a city in your Colony
full-fledged but you can also create a
puppet state it will you'll you so you
get all the energy science and culture
from it but you can't choose what it
produces or customize it so uh or you
can ra raise it raise the city I mean it
decreases Health my health by 18 and
then but then the negative Health
shrinks by one each turn nice I'm gonna
make this a puppet City because I've
never done that before delightful I I
just Annex every time I don't know why
well so that's the thing right and uh I
guess let's sort of as we wind the
stream down let's talk about sort of
lessons that you for so every Civ game
you play you learn lessons from it like
that each round you figure new stuff out
you figure different stuff out and of
course because we're playing this uh you
know because we're playing this for the
first time it's uh we're learning a lot
so one of the things I've learned is
like maybe expending a lot maybe
building a lot of cities like how these
cities are kind of close to each other
might not be a great idea like you can
like this is this city is reaching one
two three four hex's away from
its from the center so they can be
really big however I did want access to
this yeah I mean the the obviously the
closer they are the more they're
competing for those those resources
forces and the less you can expand
outward but at the same time having your
cities close together means you can send
troops or units from one city to the
other more quickly it's the if you want
to link them via roads it's less of a
process and the the shorter the roads
the less energy uh maintenance cost so
that's true there's certainly pros and
cons there uh there's an intruder in our
territory those are just aliens um
another thing that I've sort of I'm
grappling with is
wondering like about my whole trade
situation I have so many trade units oh
yeah cracking
attack oh and you're dead you got pretty
close to to beating that cracken that
was pretty solid I like I like the trade
vessels just like oh
I like the idea of just like all
those Traders like looking off the B off
the off the St or port side being like
holy crap did you see that that mountain
just Sun our boat we got to get out of
here
um so yeah it was it's kind of an
interesting perspective to to play a Civ
when you
are like not targeting the end game but
kind of fun to mess around I mean I
guess what what would I do like I could
expand to this whole new continent um
but is that worth the sort of energy
expenditure of creating new cities and
the health because my cities get pretty
unhealthy in the next couple turns yeah
uh because I also annexed and so like
you know it's just sort of trying to
figure out the new ways that these
systems go together um so you and I did
uh so actually what any any sort of
takeaways from you and stuff that's
intrigued you or problems you ran into
that you'll tackle differently next time
uh I feel like I got a kind of a lucky
role of the dice because I was never
antagonized by any of the other factions
so I could kind of like take my time
build up my troops focus on amassing a
pretty sizable Army before I went after
the Pan Asian
cooperative I feel like most times I'm
not going to have that level of peace
and quiet and I'm probably going to get
provoked a little bit more often yeah
people might be up in your face a little
bit more yeah so so I don't know I um
one thing that I looking back I wish
watching your stream now is that I kind
of played it really safe with my spies
in terms of like covert potential I feel
like if I had actually sent them out
like taken the time to look at the
opportunities that existed in by sending
them out to other cities there's some
cool stuff I could have done oh dude I
Robble Robble the hell out of all those
people and sometimes they're not
detected sometimes they are in the
Intrigue re level rises so I'm not sure
like I feel like being very Cavalier
with spies might get me in trouble
eventually but certainly at this point
of the game yeah it was a big benefit
yeah definitely um yeah that's probably
probably the big takeaways for me um
yeah Advent it's funny like I was
focusing so much on getting that
Supremacy Victory and then turn 200
rolled around around and I was like
maybe I should do something else maybe I
should just uh go mess with somebody
yeah that'd be fun yeah uh all right so
folks that's civilization beyond Earth
uh what is the release date on this
thing just uh October October 24th so
about a month from now game's coming out
uh we have a preview going up later
today probably uh Sean and I talking
more about our experiences showing a
little bit more in-depth footage of uh
different stuff we encountered and sort
of talking a bit about the affinities
and the tech web and excuse me stuff
like that so keep an eye out for that
and that's about it that's it that's it
cool uh alien life forms rule robots
drool thanks for watching folks not
catch you next
time